multi-player roles in order for us to
get the result
and this is a joint board with my great
quarters
rod from chicago booth
joshua and ashwin from google research
and my phd student
francisco susan from mit
okay so uh the main motivation behind
this work is coming from many
applications in modern online
marketplaces uh so think about like
share economies internet advertising and
cloud platforms in all of these uh
modern online marketplaces
there are real time interaction between
user and marketplaces and because of
these real-time interactions these
marketplaces
can learn and optimize at the same time
but learning and optimization at the
same time tend to be quite challenging
because first of all they have future
uncertainty
and then uh we also need to deal with
time-batting environments as we are like
learn and optimize at the same time
and more importantly we have we need to
deal with this computational complexity
because in many like setting uh the the
decision set for this optimization
problem that marketplaces are facing is
exponentially large
and then if one naively try to
experiment with every single possible
options then we are going to have a very
impractical algorithm
so then given these challenges here's
our high level goal we want to see if we
can enable decision making for modern
online marketplaces by doing learning
and optimization at the same time
despite having these three fundamental
challenges
so here are a couple of examples to make
it like concrete and give you like some
context what i mean by uh
problems and optimization in modern
online marketplaces
one is assortment planning uh so uh
student planning in a student planning
the goal is to decide what sort of items
you want to show to customers in order
to maximize
market share or revenue and this is a
problem that many companies face just
think about amazon every time you go on
amazon and search for something amazon
needs to decide what set of items it
wanted shows to on the first page so
another problem is product ranking and
think about platforms like expedia again
every time you go there like a expedia
needs to decide how they want to display
the products in what order it wants to
display the products because there are a
lot of empirical evidence out there that
hot things are being displayed influence
greatly influenced customer decisions
and as a result it influenced
marketplaces revenue and mortgage
and last but not least as another
example that and another problem that
marketplace has faced we have reserve
price optimization in only advertising
market where the goal is to optimize a
personalized reserve pricing for
advertisers while we are selling ad
views we are running
auctions okay so
now these are like some concrete example
now let's try to revisit these like
three challenges for this application
and see that if these challenges are
actually real for them
uh so the first two challenges were
future uncertainty and time varying
environments
so you can see that for restaurant
planning demand is uncertain and time
varying for product ranking uh customer
search behavior are on certain and time
bearing even if am i looking at myself
as a customer
i see that my i there's a lot of
variation in my like
personal shopping experience and
sometimes i want to spend a lot of time
like making decisions sometimes i try to
make things quick
for a surprise optimization what is like
uncertain and time-barring is going to
be your advertiser's
valuation
but let's look at the third challenge
which which is important and the third
challenge is because for many
optimization problems the decision set
is exponentially large
so um
that's certainly the case for assuming
planning the number of assortments that
one needs to try is exponentially large
and under some modelling assumption you
can write this problem as maximizing
submodular function subject to some
cardinality constraint for example
for product ranking the number of
rankings that one needs to try is again
exponentially large exponential number
of items and again under some modeling
assumption this problem is np hard you
can write it as maximizing sequential
submersible function
and for reserve price optimization the
same thing you'll have the np hardness
result for that problem
what are you trying to optimize so you
can have like different objectives so
one objective could be like maximizing
consumer engagement which is the
probability that
you get the maximum number of kidney
from the customer you could have if in
case like um
you're getting commission you're selling
things uh
like expedia maybe you try to maximize
your revenue uh uh so you can have like
various
uh depending on the platform so for like
social media platform a good maybe
objective is customer uh engagement
maximizing customer engagement but for
platforms like maybe amazon maybe
maximizing revenue
for
or they may have like if they think
about like their long-term goals they
can also try to maximize their market
share which is equivalent to uh
maximizing consumer inflation so it'd be
hard sort of a worst case but if you
pose some restrictions it might become a
simpler problem
uh np hardness is for the worst case yes
but yeah
this problem is hard because i think
they're coming into their pictures
any other questions
okay so then what we are going to do for
all these problems you want to learn and
optimization the optimization at the
same time and in the rest of the talk
what i'm going to do i'm just going to
focus on this problem and so then
planning to maximize market share as the
running example to illustrate our
thinking
okay so um
for those of you who that you are not
familiar with assuming planning bear
with me is just
what i'm going to describe is simple
optimization problem and uh as so then
if you learn that if you are okay with
that optimization problem we can
uh you can follow the rest of them
the rest of the talk so in assortment
planning we have end products
and then the goal is to choose a set or
assortment s with cardinality at most k
that maximizes market share where the
market share is the probability that one
of the item at least one of the items
within the set is being purchased or it
is being chosen
so this f function i'm going to refer to
it as a market share or demand function
so what is what you want to kind of know
about this problem is that undervalued
choice model is f is monotone and
submersion
and that's the only thing i wanted to
remember from that problem
so now
let's think about the offline version of
that problem when we do the optimization
over there i know that not this a
function this demand function and my
goal is choose set as a star that
maximizes this demand function uh
subject to carbon articles
and this problem has shown to be np-half
and that's related to the chair
challenge that i was talking about
having like computational complexity
so uh this is important to exactly the
understand definition of f
or is it an afternoon it's a monotone
[ __ ]
less for now let's say that i don't care
about it's uh it's
it's definition it could be like any uh
sub modular maximization
um function uh because for like language
choice model like new seminal i mean
nested logic model all of these things
this f is monotonous
and that's the only thing we care about
so the form doesn't matter
that's a good question and the s can be
any set
or there are visibility constraints
so here like s can be any set
that i have is the cardinality
but this is just a running example to
illustrate
so um
now let's look at the online learning
problem because remember i didn't care
about this real-time interaction between
the platforms and users so in the online
learning problem every round t here is
an unknown demand function
uh f of t i don't get to observe f of t
without observing that i have to make a
choice i need to choose set sc
after choosing that set sd i get to
observe some information it could be
it could be in this full information
feedback structure when you get to
observe the entire demand function or
you could be in the band bandit feedback
structure that you get f of t at the
chosen statistic we study both of them
we have result for both but mainly in
today's study i'm just going to focus on
the pulling formation uh yes danny
ft is a probability right
so is that a set function
so so ft of st rather like how would you
observe
it's a problem
so how would you like you you just
observed one or zero
in like how would you observe the actual
probability
oh good question i think right now let's
assume that i do observe the probability
but it's not very difficult to also
consider studying that you only observe
the realization so yeah but for now
let's assume that i get to observe the
problem by having like let's say showing
that that thing today like a multiple
user and then
that's a good question
and the benchmark is in hindsight
optimal uh where in the event in
hindsight optimal i need to choose a
single set
uh that maximizes the total market share
across all the tickets
so and then in the online learning
problem that's what we are competing
against this is the in hindsight optimal
that we are competing against
now let's actually see what we want to
do here remember that i said i want to
facilitate learning and optimization at
the same time
so that means that at a very high level
i want to go from offline optimization
to the online learning regime
because the the reason that we are going
to do that is that
in many cases when you look at the
offline problem
we have a very good uh despite having
this combinatorial challenge there is
some like there exists some
approximation algorithm that gives us
good performance
so think about greedy type algorithm
primal dual technique or like um lp
relaxation your name is and these type
of like um algorithms have a good
performance guarantee but those
guarantees only hold in the offline
regime not in the online version
but they want to understand if we can
get a similar guarantee for the online
regime when we have real-time
interaction between users
and the
marketplace okay so
have that question in mind so here's
what we are going to do
i'm going to develop a
generic tool to transform this offline
algorithm that are designed for only
offline regime
and then somehow transform them to
online algorithms with a similar
performance guarantee and by similar i
mean those like when i do the
transformation their online combinance
is gonna get like similar performance be
no no performance loss when you look at
things over time
and now
if i want to become more concrete the
way we are going to do that is that we
are going to mimic
the structure of this
optimal uh this offline approximation
algorithm using the lateral approach and
that's where blackwell approachability
plays a crucial role and you may wonder
why do you even like want to mimic
offline approximation algorithm
the reason you think that mimicking is a
good idea is that these offline
approximation algorithm
tend to
exploit the combinatorial structure of
the problem
and when they do that they remove the
necessity of evaluating this
combinatorial function at every single
option
and without doing such a like extensive
evaluation they manage to return
something which is near optimal
now if i do this if i try to mimic this
uh approximation algorithm
in the online regime i can also can
exploit the combinatorial structure in a
very implicit way and by doing that i
can remove the necessity of
experimenting with every single option
and that's why i think at the very high
level mimicking this uh structure of the
offline approximation algorithm is a
good idea
and it's become more clear later what i
mean by mimicking
but for now this is at a very high level
because of the combinatorial structure i
want to mimic something that has already
taken advantage of the combinatorial
structure
any question
before i get to the details okay
so perfect
and in this one what i'm going to do is
that when it comes to this
mimicking or transforming this uh
offline approximation algorithms i'm
going to focus on a large class of
problems
that admit gritty type algorithms
okay so this their offline problem
admits a very greedy nice pretty type
algorithms uh that has a very nice
theoretical guarantee this is the case
for assortment planning for product
ranking and for reserve price
optimization for all of these problems
there are six very nice 3d algorithms
that gives us good approximation
and we are going to do the transforming
we are going to do the transformation
for this type of algorithms
okay so if the focus is on a greedy
algorithm
let me walk you through the greedy
algorithm by uh for this for our running
example maximizing submodular function
subject to cardinality constraint
and many of you may know this algorithm
it's a very elegant algorithm um it's a
kind of classical algorithm by nam sorry
tall
it's an algorithm that gives 1 minus 1
over e and this is designed for
maximizing any submodular
monotone sub-modular function
how does it work
you go over k sub problems
in sub problem i you choose element zi
or product zi
that maximizes and
the marginal market share delta s
and then you add that uh that product to
your set
you you keep doing that and until going
over okay sub problems remember k was
the cardinality
and then you return sfk as your final
finance okay so this is the algorithm
the the greedy algorithm
and you can envision the security
algorithm
in the following way so there are k sub
problems sub problem i choose zi
and then choosing zi you can think about
it as
finding the best local move for that sub
problem
and then you'll find the space local
move by going over this k sub problem
you can get the solution which is really
good it gives you 1 minus 1 over the
approximation
which is the best approximation factor
for that
okay
now
like the question that we ask ourselves
is that
is it possible to transform this offline
3d like algorithm in polynomial time to
their online conversions that get
sub-linear approximately
so first thing what is approximate
regret
so approximate regret is a regret where
you measure your performance with
respect to
gamma times the enhanced optimal where
gamma is the approximation factor of the
greedy algorithm and this is what the
algorithm gets this is going to be gamma
times the opt in hindsight the benchmark
and you may wonder why am i actually
putting gamma here
why not like calculating regret and stop
going with the approximate regret the
reason is that
the online problem is definitely much
more difficult than the offline version
and for the offline version i'm not
getting better than gamma approximation
so the best thing that i'm hoping to do
is getting a sublinear regret with
respect to
gamma times optimum
and if i do that so then i can say
that's a good result because pretty much
i get like similar performance in the
online regime without knowing all this
like reward function of it
okay so no i think like
after that things getting like quite
nice because now uh actually they're
like i can get to show you the uh the
the elegance of blackboard
approachability and how it plays a role
in our transformation
so what i'm gonna do in the rest of the
talk i'm gonna provide you with like a
framework
that framework needs to generate
conditions
one is related to blackfall
approachability
and then i'll show you that
under this select these two generic
conditions you can do this
transformation get the sublinear gamma
regress
and for for the online regime and then
i'm going to also show you that for a
large class of class of problems that
admit guilty type algorithms these two
conditions are simply sets
that's very
so
now
here are the two conditions
the first condition is called robustness
of gradient algorithm to local errors
so remember that in a greedy algorithm
i'm going over k sub problems
to build a solution now imagine that in
every sub problem instead of
doing my local task optimally i do it
with a little bit of mistakes a little
bit of error
under this robustness condition i want
the error across different sub problems
don't get pro package don't get
amplified i just want the errors simply
add up together
or even like get aggregated in a
sublingual fashion
that's what i mean by robustness
condition
now the second condition is blackberry
lookout
this blackwell locality condition one
requires that every subproblem i that i
have
can be cast as a black filter and i'm
really glad that i'm giving this talk
after uh then i saw by rockets because
right now you have like some might be
some good idea about what the blackfall
game is but i'm still gonna like give
you refresh your memory but um and then
later tell you why these two conditions
are actually nice to have and gives us
the result that we want
okay so let's get to the like uh provide
some information about this blackwell
game uh you've seen it in the in rockets
as
the question about the first condition
so is the error in the function itself
the payoff or is it an error in i'm
choosing the wrong action and somehow
that doesn't matter so let's say that
the best local move is returning your
item that there has been uh my maximum
margin right this is your local move now
let's say that i'm returning a
distribution over products and then i
want the expected marginals to be
maximum this is kind of equivalent to
doing this local move optimally we're
saying it's not doing finding this the
local move optimally like exactly
returning your item that maximizes the
marginal i give you uh some like uh
some distribution over products such
that expected marginal market share is
still not too far from the
maximum thing that you don't know
and that's that's what i mean by l
and i if that if we make an error in
making this a local move i want the
error overall in terms of the final
things that you are getting this f of t
at the chosen set to be uh to be uh
small
any other question
thank you for the question okay so now
what what's the natural game because uh
for all transformations quite crucial
let's look at this repeated blackville
games and then repeat that's gonna be
lightweight games i have like two
players p1 and p2
and uh it is a zero-sum game
and then then the important things as
rubbish mentioned is that in this game
the payoff is a vector
and it's also more importantly the
payoff should be by alpha
by finding the decision made by the the
two players
so in every round t player p1 is going
to choose an action xt player p2 is
going to choose an action by t
then after that p1 obtains the payoff at
the chosen actions and then p2 gets a
negative of that and that's what is a
zero sum game and this process like
continues
so now
what is the game the p1 wants to
approach a convex set
and p2 does not want this to happen
and then i'm saying approaching this
convex that is saying that
the distance between this uh time
average payoff that p1 gets and this
convex set s
goes to zero as t goes to infinity
so that's the thing that the uh
the p11 swatchy
now the very elegant result by blackwell
shows that if set s is approachable in
in terms of like hyperplane
approachability that rocket mentioned
which is a very easy thing to check
because you need to check something only
in a single shot like that game rather
than in a repeated setting
then
there exists a strategy for p1 in the
repeated game that no matter what p2
does
p1 can actually approach that target
convex
and
very amazingly like in the when you look
at the proof of the block
approachability the proof also tells you
what is the strategy that p1 needs to
use in order to approach these targets
not only tells you that the p1 can
approach that target set it also tell
you how but with the help of what
algorithm
this approachability is possible
so
what i want you to remember from this
slide is that
if set s is well behaved
then there is an albulightful algorithm
alec b that helps p1 to target the the
complex
so that's the only thing i want you to
remember
now now let's try to put these two
condition together and let me tell you
why this this is kind of based on these
two conditions i can i can manage to
transform offline algorithms to their
online
counterparts
so remember that we had this political
locality
that wants us to to cast every sub
problem on
as a blackfield game which means that i
need to come up with two imaginary
players come up with some by a fine
payoff vector
that are
and some the like approachable target
convex set and once this happens i would
say okay here is a like a algb like
algorithm that is going to help this
player uh p1 to generate a sequence of
actions that maybe they are not locally
based but they're almost locally based
when you look at things in average of it
okay so here is what we are going to do
uh sub problem one is going to be
handled by bilateral algorithm b1
lp1 is going to decide about the the
first product that we are going to add
to the set
it's going to pass its decision to the
another block algorithm the other
blocker algorithm make a decision about
the second product
and this whole thing is continue until
going over this k support
and the reason i can handle this every
sub problem with the blackwell game
is because of the black and locality
connection
and now
then what about the second condition
what about robustness to local errors
so the robustness to local errors is
actually quite nice because it allow me
to glue everything together
but i don't care about like each of
these sub problems separately i do care
about the final product after going over
all these k sub problems
so robustness to local errors allow me
to uh make sure that when every sub
problems is being handled by blackfield
with some error let's say in the order
of a square root t
then overall after going over k sub
problems the final like error or the
regret is going to be k times that which
is going to be k times the square root t
roughly
any question about the high level idea
before i move on
i'm gonna like revisit this high level
ideas uh later but
i wanna see if there is any um
any question about that so so you're
gonna have k
different blackwell games
that are played every round
uh they are gonna like at least for that
problem they are working in a sequential
fashion but yeah in every round there
are a case of uh cable rifle algorithms
each of them are responsible for
uh so then like my action is tied across
these cases like i can't pick a
different action for each game or can i
no let's say that our
blackwell algorithm one decide about
either one so then i don't want a
condition on this like item being chosen
blackwell algorithm two that decide
about the second item it wants to add to
that set so they are kind of this is
actually very nice these the local
algorithms communicate with each other
it's not like they are not being run
entirely so and in other words they're
mimicking the structure of the greedy
algorithm
so this making decision pass this
decision to the next one and based on
that the next one makes a decision
thank you nico for the question
thanks
isn't the robustness assumption
restrictive because i think the greedy
image take some optimal decisions that
affect them long term
so good question i think this robustness
condition first of all is important for
us because uh if if you do each of these
tasks like almost square doesn't that
may not mean that overall you are to get
a good solution and there are some 3d
type algorithm that are not locally
robust but as uh
as i was actually gonna tell you then
you are ahead of me for all this like
problem that i talk about a student
planning product ranking and reserve
price optimization
we have the robustness competition
condition so there are like a various
problems that this condition can be
satisfied but not not that this
condition may not be always sense
thank you
um other advantages
the robustness property and the fact
that you have um you know natural splits
of your problem nature and to you know
some fixed number of sub problems uh how
else would you be using sort of like
that you're working with the greedy
algorithms
that's the only thing if you didn't read
the algorithm and i try and i break it
down into like multiple sub problems
then i can if i can show that every like
small task every sub problem can be cast
as a bilateral game and then you have
the robustness that you cannot fall out
from
that's other than that
okay so um
no i think that was the contribution uh
as you as i explained so here in this
world we design an
efficient framework to do to go from
offline uh to online setting and our
transformation crucially uses political
approachability and it needs these two
condition robustness to local errors and
the local locality and
for any like problem as long as you
satisfy these two condition
you get a square root t regret for the
full information setting until the power
of two third regret for the bandit city
and um when we came up with this like
framework we were quite excited because
we applied to a wide range of
application in operation and markets
and as
as you can see here in all of these
applications we managed to show that
these conditions are satisfied and um
then when we applied we got the either
got the first bond for these problems or
like um matches the best known one the
literature or even like uh improve them
so here um
so here for example we applied to
product ranking reserve price
optimization various submodular
optimization problem continuous uh and
discrete and subject to various
constraints so you will see that for
full information studying we get a
square root of dependency
for the banded setting when the decision
that is discrete we get to power up two
there
and when you when the decisions are
because become like continuous because
of the discretization error the regret
is either two power of four fifths or
zero power of five six
and um
another thing that we find it quite
exciting is that when you look at this
uh result for the band is studying in
the prior work
uh although the band is setting is very
realistic and um it's kind of like
what's happening in uh what you would
need to have like a practical algorithm
you will see this column is quite sparse
uh prior that work and we were excited
to contribute to the literature by
providing the first bonds for for the
bandwidth setting for various problems
um okay so
i know that today we are going to talk
about blackboard approachability but in
case you are also like
kind of like wondering what is the
literature about this offline to online
transformation uh maybe i can make a few
remarks about that so first thing is
that you cannot always do this offline
to online transformation okay so there
are negative results in literature that
for some combinatorial problems it's not
actually possible to do that that's a
nice result but it has on quran 2016.
the other thing that i want to mention
about this offline to online
transformation usually prior work
take a black box approach meaning that
they assume that there's an oracle for
the offline setting that you can call
and then based on that you decide like
how to actually make a decision in
online
so we don't take a blackbox reduction
approach
and we we actually do care about what's
happening inside the offline algorithm
and we take advantage of the structure
of this offline approximation algorithm
so and speaking of um this black box
reduction there are a nice paper like
call of apollo 2005 and do dikital 2017
nikko actually uh has a nice paper on
that that they uh do this offline to
online transformation but
for them uh they need the the oracle for
the offline problem to be exact which is
not the case for us because we are
dealing for np-hard problems
and then there's also this nice work
alpha daytona 2019 they also take the
black box reduction approach but for
approach it's crucial to have linear
reward which is not again the case for
us even for assortment planning that i
discussed we don't have linearity
and uh that's why like prior works
cannot be applied to ourselves so the
bottom line is that in this world we
look at this np-hall problem with
non-linear reward structure and
we use the like elegance and magic of
likewise approachability to do the
transformation from offline to online
and we got results for both full
information and bandwidth
so
any question before i move on to more
details
so then if there is no question let me
as i promise i'm going to provide you
high level sketch of our approach and
because this day is actually dedicated
to blackwell i just want to show you how
this how is it actually possible to cast
our sub problem as a blindfold game and
how this help us like to get the result
that we want
so remember at the very like high level
we wanted to mimic the 3d algorithm this
is what we wanted to do when it when we
wanted to go from offline to online
and then that means that every later on
i want to go over this like i saw
problems to make a decision kind of
roughly speaking
so if that's what we are going to do
maybe here is like one idea what if for
like every sub problem i like for
example you run t i choose product z i
that maximizes this marginal
okay
can i actually do that meaning that can
i make this best local move the answer
is unfortunately no because you don't
have the knowledge of f of t when you
are making that decision so then you
cannot really mimic this through the
algorithm in this way
in this like naive approach
so instead what we say
what if i try to look at these sub
problems across all the t runs
and say that
let's make sure that every sub problem i
make a sequence of actions that are
almost locally based
uh but an average sense of worth
and maybe that that by doing that we
were able to kind of mimic the structure
of the
greedy algorithm and in fact
this is possible under this black
locality condition under black and
locality condition i can just focus on
this sub problem across neurons and then
uh create a sequence of actions that are
almost locally best when looking at
things over time
so let's actually
revisit the greedy algorithm to provide
more information about how this
blackboard locality condition is
satisfied and how i can cast it as a
black building
remember that it's a problem i
i'm choosing a product vi that maximizes
the marginal market share
okay so then
choosing a ci that maximizes market
share is equivalent to say that this
payoff is payoff vector which is a
vector actually is greater than equals
zero
so let me parse it for you so this is
the marginal under product the is the
marginal under product one so if vi is
the one that maximize marginal of course
this difference should be positive okay
and that's the same thing for all the
other coordinates
so now i have i
saying that z i maximizes the marginal
is equivalent to say that this payoff is
positive is in the positive voltage
and there's the issue because if i want
to cast it as a blackfield game i don't
see the linearity in the eye
and actually for blackwell it's crucial
that the vector payoff to be by a fine
and i don't have it so i'm going to
massage this a little bit not a very
fancy trick but it's going to help me so
let's assume that the greedy chooses
distribution over products rather than
returning a product and then then i can
write uh payoff in terms of this
distribution theta i
and that's without loss of generality
because if i have a product that
maximizes marginal then i can say that i
put a mass of one on that particular
part
so then this yellow thing that you see
here is just simply the expected value
of marginal market share at the greedy
decision
and
now
what i did this is again you can see
that this payoff should be positive but
the very nice thing is that this payoff
is not linear in theta r which what i
want to touch
okay so
here is the part which is kind of i i i
think
explain how this political approach will
help us and we can cast it as a
blackpool game
so my imaginary player p1 is the
algorithm that decide about theta i
my imaginary p2 is in nature that
chooses this delta f
the payoff that i have is again the same
payoff that i i show you is a vector is
definitely by a fine in theta i and
delta
so everything is nice
and also the target set what actually p1
wants to achieve is that this payoff to
be positive because if this payoff is
positive that means that
i choose the item that maximizes the
marginal so that means that the target
set is simply the positive part
and it's easy to see that it's
approachable yes
s i minus 1 is actually a function of t
and this doesn't create problems no it
doesn't create any problem and then here
i'm just to
make sure that something be like your
sub problem i can be classed as a
lightweight game you need to be looking
at the single shot like those uh single
shot will actually so and that's another
nice thing because checking the
condition is very easy
and then yeah it doesn't matter that's a
function
so
now i define everything i wanted two
imaginary layers a payoff vector which
is by applying a target set which is uh
convex and approachable and uh then then
i showed that you can cast it as a
velcro game and if that's the case
there's a strategy this political
strategy that health player p1 which is
our algorithm for that sub problem one
to to actually approach this set meaning
that makes the almost locally
optimal move for that particular suffer
and again like here i just revisit the
high level ideas because of the variable
locality i can uh handle every sub
problem i with a black belt game
and that's uh
and then after that they pass the
information make a decision and because
of the robustness error the outcome is
going to be a still has a nice property
because the error does not get amplified
so uh
that's right like and then we get this
full information like we get this under
full information setting which is uh as
long as you have the robustness to a
local condition uh to local errors and
your life will local
you can go from offline to online and
then get a regret which is in the order
of k square root t where k is the number
of sub problems yes
what information is transferred
so the beginning of every round
okay so yes the question is that how do
i like what's the information structure
so let's say
it's a problem i'll make a decision and
then after that the only thing i need to
pass a problem to is the item chosen
and then after like so problem one and
some problem to make a decision about uh
item one product one and product two i
need to just pass that set to the next
the local algorithm just literally uh
following what the greedy algorithm does
in the offensive so that's the
information and then for the full
information study after i made all this
decision
i get to observe the entire function the
f of t and then i pass that to the
velocity algorithm so that they can
update themselves
but the bandwidth settings become more
complicated because i only get one
pieces of information
and then uh the question is that which
of them are gonna handle like i'm gonna
pass that information you handle that
but for the full information setting you
can just pass that information
okay
yes
so actually very good question i think
that we are actually working on that
we believe that for like a dynamic
programming type algorithm you can still
follow the same thing as long as there
is no loop in the structure of the uh
structure of the algorithm you can do
that so let's say that you can represent
the algorithm in phone number like a dag
and then you have like a small number of
states uh in your like dynamic
programming algorithm you can still
apply that under like some condition
yeah some like partial result that you
can do it for example for knapsack for
the dp design for an access
and you can also apply to frankfurt type
of algorithm
so there is nothing like
especially about 3d as long as it can
satisfy robustness to local errors as
well as the
blackboard locality condition as long as
you can check that you can and then
there is no loop in the system like a
cycle in the system so then you can
apply this technique so it's very it's
very powerful
uh yes yes the question is next to local
errors is this basically a property of
nema houses algorithms exactly so is
there a property of the offering
algorithm and that's what i mean that we
are not doing the blackbox reduction i
actually care about what does it
what does the greedy algorithm does i
need to kind of take a closer look zoom
in and see that it is property in the
offering
is it important that it's incremental
that the rewards get
added up along the sequence
yeah i think
as i am
it's kind of related to the question
that's triple as long as you don't need
to like to have a change like that you
can have things like that are completely
parallel you can also have things that
uh in form of a dab
uh so that things like passes along
multiple like uh like passes a longer
a lot multiple passes so then that also
uh could work
and another question is the dependency
on k here is linear is it do you think
yeah
future work to kind of try to shape
something so very nice i think i think
for this sub module optimization it's
linear but actually when we're looking
at maximizing continuous of modular
function subject to
downward close convex set be sure that
this robustness condition is even like
better like meaning that it's getting
the error gets applicated aggregated in
the sublinear fashion so we improved the
k to something else and that's why we
managed to get to the power of parts
because for of motion maximization you
would already have that k
so um
let me try to be quick so then maybe i
did also some simulation because i'm
very excited to see how this algorithm
performs one very nice thing is that you
observe the this cumulative gamma
regress are actually negative
which was surprising we first like
checked the code if something wrong but
then we realized that there is nothing
wrong the reason that even like the
regret is negative is that we are like
mimicking these 3d algorithms and grid
algorithms the
in the worst case they get one minus one
over e or like this gamma approximation
in practice they do much better and we
make them so that's why that in practice
uh by mimicking them you get like even
uh negative rigor again
negative approximately good
uh okay so let me summarize so with the
today um as i said it was an honor to
talk in a day dedicated to blackwell
because uh as at the gist of our
approach we crucially use the magic of
local approachability to do the
transformation from offline to online
and using this transformation we get a
square root of regret for the full
information setting until the power of
two third grade for bandit setting and
one thing we we at least find quite
amazing was the flexibility of the
framework and the fight that can be
applied to various problems uh including
product ranking reserve price
optimization and uh several uh
submodular
maximization yeah thank you so much so
uh thank you for listening to my target
question and i'll uh there's a link to
the paper my email and i will take any
question that you might have thank you
[Applause]
to make a brief attempt to get back a
little closer to schedule after the
break uh i think let's take questions
offline and let's take a shorter than
expected break do you want to
come back at 11 10 said
or 1105.
so it says 1105. not my fault five
minutes five minute break see you soon